hello everyone and welcome to another
incredibly exciting game uh from the
classical portion of the uh norway chess
2022 it's a vessel in topalov versus
vishwanathan anand and this is their
73rd uh
classical game that the two of them are
playing if you guys are interested in
their current score head to head it's 19
wins for anand 13 wins for topalov and
40 draws and this is now their 73rd game
uh which is just incredible they know
each other very well and
the the games are always uh well very
very enjoyable now this game uh here at
time uh played a kind of a crucial
factor uh
but only seemingly as as you'll see the
real problem for this game was that it's
impossible to calculate all the lines
because the lines in this game are
uh crazy and super enjoyable as you'll
see so let's uh let's check it out uh
topalov has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 anand replies with d5 and
we have c4 offering the queen's gambit
uh and uh anand accepts d characters on
c4 and this is incredibly sharp if you
don't know how to accept the gambit uh
you do not accept the gambit they say
you know in the olden days they said
that the queen's gambit is not really a
gambit because usually uh gambits are
best accepted uh you know they said that
gambits are best refuted if accepted but
queen's gambit maybe not so much so here
accepting the gambit very very uh cool
stuff uh e4 uh on and uh moved for away
from the center so uh topalov grabs the
full center b5 now defending the pawn as
apollo was ready to capture it and now
a4 we have to challenge this um
queenside expansion anand created c6
defending and now
a captures on b5 is the most common way
to play this but uh topalov plays
knights to c3 he invites anans to play
b4 and this is exactly what anand plays
we have b4 and now knight back to b1
knight the a2 is a more popular retreat
but topalov has a different idea he
plays knight b1
and now again he's ready to capture back
on c4 so bishop to a6 defending and now
the power plays queen to c2 now he's
threatening to capture back on c4 but he
also gives up the d4 pawn there which is
very strange you create a full center
and then you just give up the d4 pawn
but this is all standard stuff of the
queen's gambit accepted so queen
captures on d4 on and grabs the pawn
knight f3 developing and now this is
where the game really begins uh it's not
a new position but basically uh the
engine tells you that all the retreats
are are great so it's basically your
choice what kind of a game you want to
play that's uh where you retreat so here
onan plays queen to d7 uh and now bishop
captures on c4 and here we reach new
territory uh because for example in 2011
in bilbao arunyan had this position
against pakoe however e6 was played
arunian was able to win that game but
here we have bishop cactus on c4 by
anand and it is now already as of move 9
that we have a completely new game so
queen captures on c4 you have to grab
back the piece and now pawn to e6 uh uh
topolov continues development bishop to
e3 we have knight to f6 uh knight b to
d2 and now bishop to e7 and here both
players just castle so castles castles
uh trying to finish development rook
after d1 aligning the rook nicely with
the queen on the open d file uh but you
don't really have any good discovery so
not worried about that he plays uh an
incredibly active move and that is pawn
to c5 which seems impossible because uh
it's uh attacked twice and defended only
once but that's exactly what ananda does
he gives back a little bit of of
material to develop his queen side as
quickly as possible
so to paul of captures it is the
strongest move bishop captures on c5 and
now rook to c8 pins the bishop knight to
b3 defends the bishop and now queen to
c7 attacking the bishop three times uh
but now just queen to b5 and this is the
strongest uh move that is uh available
here it seems like you're blundering a
piece but not really because anand's
back rank is weak uh if you actually
capture the bishop here then we just
capture everything and once the queen
captures you you get to checkmate at
rook d8 check knight blocks and this is
now checkmate so this is how topology
unpinned so anand plays a6 chases away
the queen uh queen captures on b4 and
now just knight to c6 now he gets some
development in attacks the queen queen
back to e1 defending the e4 pawn and now
rook a to b8 and now ananda is fully
developed we have bishop captures on e7
the power of traits here queen captures
and now knight after d2 and uh okay
topalov is up a pawn but uh look at the
position uh anan's rooks are beautifully
placed on the bnc file uh you you can't
really defend the b2 pawn your knight is
attacked if you move the knight you lose
the pawn so for the moment you have to
play a move like uh
knight after d2 so queen to b4 putting
more pressure on the b file and also
putting pressure on the a4 pawn so it's
hard to bring this rook into the game
queen to e2 by topalov and now knight to
d4 attacking the queen and then b3 so
you have to capture so knight captures
on d4 queen captures and now as the b2
pawn is attacked we play pawn to b3 and
now it's defended but still the knight
is on d2 it's not a not a great square
for the knight so here h6 anand creates
a little bit of reading room for the
king so you don't have to worry about
your back rank issues and now how can
topolo
start developing it's uh it seems like
whatever move he makes it's just uh
insufficient he would like to move the
knight but the knight here uh both the
e4 pawn is attacked and the knight is
the defender of the e4 pawn and also the
knight is a defender of the b3 pawn so
you can't really move the knight uh it's
hard to to move the rooks uh so here
topolov comes up with rook to a2 ah now
uh
if this rook ever moves the the rook
will not be a target here uh and uh also
it serves as a defender for the knight
so now you can move this rook so here we
have a5 uh now uh i'm blockading the
entire queen side so this is now a
backwards spawn and it doesn't really
matter that topolo has two to one
advantage here you are never going to be
able to move this pawn as long as the
rooks are in the game so here h3 the
paolo also creates some breeding room
for his king now comes queen to b4 uh we
have queen back to e1 and now rook to c3
just mounting the pressure and it's very
very hard for topolof to make moves we
have rook to b2 now adding more defense
to the to the b3 pawn and now rook to d8
so how do you continue here uh we have
rook d to b1 and now knight to d7 now
anand is bringing the knight over to c5
to put more pressure on the b3 pawn we
have queen to e2 and now comes rook to
b8 here knight to the e5 is also very
much playable the knight is excellent on
e5 and
for one it prevents the white knight
from coming to c4 but anand plays rook
to b8 because it's an incredibly tricky
move and also he's playing on topalov's
time topalo is already uh below four
minutes uh and he still needs to make
nine more moves to reach time control
and the position is just incredibly
complicated just to give you an example
uh if the apollo one to calculate knight
to c4 here uh four minutes would not be
enough and just to give you an example
and it's a crucial move to calculate if
you can play knight to c4 you are fine
uh but okay let's say knight to c5 we
put more pressure here now e5 is the
move to play so even just this
requires a lot of time to calculate but
now let's see what happens if black
actually starts capturing rook captures
on b3 rook captures on b3 knight
captures on b3 now white has knight to
d2 and that's uh that would be a problem
so you can't just start capturing on b3
and here if queen captures on a4 there's
queen to d3 now putting more pressure on
the knight here you can't move the
knight because the rook hangs so here we
would play queen to a2 and now you get
queen to d6 attacking the rook here rook
to b7 sorry rook to b7 not b6 and now we
just deliver a check king h7 we deliver
another check now the queen attacks the
knight here and after g6 we capture on
b3 very nicely done let's say rook
captures knight captures a white is up a
piece but now comes a4 uh alan would
have a past pawn here for example knight
the c5 attacks the pawn queen to b2 now
if knight captures we just play queen to
a1 check and we pick up the knight on a4
so here it would be it would be tricky
but uh you know with perfect play it's a
draw but with perfect play everything's
a draw so i mean uh after anan's rook
the b8 move uh knight to c for with four
minutes on the clock impossible to
calculate so the power plays rook to d1
uh and now anand uh just continues
mounting the pressure knight to c5 we
have rook b back to b1 and now uh rook
to d3 again anand just keeps the
pressure on and could trade everything
off with knight captures on b3 but
there's no reason to do this
specifically because uh topalov is so
solo on time and this is uh what the
paolo most likely wanted on him to play
uh because there's this very tricky
queen to h5 move it seems like a crazy
move like it does absolutely nothing but
the actual idea is after queen captures
on a4 we're gonna play knight captures
on b3 rook captures on b3 rook captures
on b3 and after queen captures play rook
to d7 that's the idea of queen to h5 we
go after the f7 pawn and also once black
defends this we are going to pick up the
a5 pawn so black will not keep the
outside pass pawn and it will be equal
material it's a it's a draw so uh anand
says nope not not going to happen he
just continues mounting pressure rook to
d3 and now e5 very hard to find moves
for paulo but he he manages the to find
them the knight is no longer atar the
pawn is no longer a target on e4 uh rook
to d5 now by anand
finally knight to c4 a beautiful square
for the knight also defending the e5
pawn and now again can anand capture on
b3 well let's check it out if knight
captures on b3 uh there's rook captures
on d5 this is what the paul prepared and
now if he captures on d5 there's knight
to d2 and this is just now big big
problem for for anand uh you can't
really capture if queen captures then
you just fall apart just queen captures
on d2 and now if knight captures of
course rook captures nb8 with check and
rook will defeat a knight in this
endgame very easily so what would
actually happen after knight to d2 queen
captures on a4 and now we play e6 and
topalov now wins this no questions asked
for example if captures queen captures
which check king h8 uh better yet king
h8 queen h7 doesn't really matter you're
gonna get there uh either way rook
captures on b3 and now after rook
captures on b3 now we force the king to
the h7 square so it doesn't really
matter king h7 queen to c2 with check
and now we pick up the rook king back to
h8 now we pick up the rook and that's it
okay black has the two pawns but the
knight and queen will uh will uh defeat
them so uh that's the problem here so
ananda doesn't try to capture on b3 he
plays rook captures on d1 queen captures
on d1 and now uh finally knight captures
on a4 this is how anand wins back the
pawn and now uh how do you how do you
continue playing this uh well of course
you cannot capture because the queen
captures on b1 rook to a1 by topolov now
knight to c3 attacking the queen and you
have to be careful one wrong move and
you blunder the queen so you can't have
that so here after knight to c3 topalov
really went into a deep think which uh
was necessary but not uh possible uh
because he did not have any more time
and he played queen to d6 uh but it was
uh before he actually hit the clock that
his time ran out and it was in this
position on move 37 or basically on move
36 that uh wesleyan topalov lost the
game on time and ananda wins his second
classical game in a row and it's a this
position it's uh it's always going to be
slightly better for anand but uh not
enough to push so uh for example if you
capture on b3 we're going to capture on
a5 attack the queen here for example
queen b2 will attack the rook and now
rook moves somewhere the game continues
equal material it's a bit more
comfortable for for anand to play this
as his pieces are placed better uh but
like i said uh with perfect play it's a
draw but with perfect play everything's
a draw so uh it's a
anand wins this game on time but now
that you've actually seen the lines you
know that he did not win this game on
time he just won it because it was
impossible for for topalov to calculate
everything
so yeah
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
it very very nicely done with this win
uh these are the standings so let me
just uh uh uh
remove the uh make this a little bit
smaller so these are the standings uh
via chess 24 website uh there you have
it
in clear first place the only one who
won both of his classical games uh
followed by wesley so with four and a
half as uh we're we're going to cover uh
that game as well from the second round
in third place on each giri with three
two and a half uh mamadyarov and magnus
carlsen with two bangha and aryanthari
with one and a half teemu rajabov with
one and a half maxima shiloh graph and
vessel into paulov with one point after
losing this game to anand and also uh
you guys might be interested in this so
let me just uh quickly load this up
uh sorry i haven't prepared it
beforehand uh these are the world's top
12. and as you can see uh these are the
live ratings of course anand uh
anand comes back into the world top 10
in classical chess after winning his two
games and now he's number nine ahead of
geary nakamura and maksim bashir lagrav
so really really impressive stuff by
anand uh we'll see if he can continue uh
his onslaught in classical chess so uh
you know good things are happening in
the chess world uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it always be
mindful of your time but sometimes it's
just not possible as uh
there's just too much to calculate uh i
would like to thank andre theron um
alexander john juarez valentin moreira i
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to lucas wang and i would like to thank
anand legend for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the norway
chess
2022 until it finishes so thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day